welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in Thor broaden the horizons of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe with cosmic
scale New Mexico directed by Kenneth
Branagh with the weight of Shakespeare
the movie gave us a future badass
Avenger most of us could one day cosplay
ass and an origin of science magic with
difficult to pronounce Norwegian terms
Mia Mia what's Mia we're gonna keep this
infinity saga quarantine re-watch series
going with another scene-by-scene
breakdown of all the new details that
you might have overlooked from this film
and the deeper reason why Thor it's
actually a very different film than you
might remember okay before I begin this
is more than a Thor story Thor does grow
up a bit but I wouldn't call his change
transformational he even admits at the
end that he's not yet worthy of the
coronation that's deferred in the
opening that coronation doesn't come
full circle until Thor Ragnarok once
Thor has truly transformed you think
about it Thor actually played a similar
role in Avengers infinity war beginning
as a drifting exile smacking up on a
windshield completing a similar trial to
regain his mighty weapon and the kill
shots of Thor versus the destroyer and
Thor versus Thanos have maxie and
framing but infinity war was not Thor's
movie either
Thanos was the protagonist of infinity
war now Thor fought hard to stop him but
his aim sucked and Thanos prevailed and
Thanos his leading role in that chapter
began after he snatched the secret hero
role from Loki so as we re watch Thor I
will be making the argument that Loki is
this movie's secret hero the opening
shot of the film is a starry desert sky
now Kenneth Branagh revealed that the
original prologue was going to be the
cosmic Hubble telescope inspired imagery
of the nine realms that rolled during
the credits the idea was that this
Marvel film would be the first to bring
the mysteries of the cosmos into this
world we then flashed back to 965 ad in
tonsberg norway a setting revisited in
Captain America the First Avenger and
the future home of new Asgard and
Avengers end game war rages between the
Asgardians led by Odin and the frost
giants of jötunheimr fee now this is all
based on Marvel Comics which took its
thor Lord from actual Norse mythology
Odin rules over the Norse gods and in
Marvel Comics he is one of the most
powerful figures
Odin loses an eye in this war in Norse
legend he actually gave up his eye to
obtain
cosmic wisdom but it's the same I that
Thor will loose when he finally steps up
to embrace the odinforce and Ragnarok
this narrated stories being told by Odin
to his two sons Thor and Loki adopted
and we actually learned later that this
was actually Loki's origin story see
capiro he was the adopted frost giant
child from that conflict even at first
shot of Asgard is a misdirect of the PC
point on its bottom side reflecting Loki
as the overlooked icy bottom side that's
truly the bedrock of all this and Odin's
vaults are a number of important
artifacts the frost giants casket of
ancient winters of course mew mew now in
the comics mule near contains the
inscription whosoever holds this hammer
if he be where they shop is that somehow
though though it's not on the MCU
version but the designers did include
that disc with elder futhark runes
translating to he who wields this hammer
commands the lightning and the storm
there's also the tuning fork a device ii
summon monsters the eternal flame which
later plays a role in thor ragnarok to
summon search her the warlocks i which
can control people's minds in the tablet
of life and time which connects sends
one's life time and the visible runes on
it translate to those who sit probably
reading fully to those who sit above and
shadow which is the name of the gods to
the gods who oversee the Asgardians
there's also a right-handed Infinity
Gauntlet that was snuck in there before
marble locked in its whole engine the
saga plans hella makes a joke about this
by calling it fake in Ragnarok but I
have always liked the theory that it was
a relic from Odin's past quest to
assemble the Infinity stones that he
backed down from after a Boromir
required the sacrifice of his daughter
hella originally there was a deleted
scene that open his film that would have
introduced adult foreign Loki together
as equals pre coronation Thor would have
another agha pledged Loki would have
turned wine in this snakes a nod to the
mythological Loki in the Midgard serpent
but instead of that true introduction
here we get the coronation showing Thor
in his classic comic get up including
the winged helmet also blonde eyebrows
okay and we need lady SIF who's actually
Thor's wife in mythology but here a
longtime friend and the warriors 3 then
draw a Hogan and Volstagg there's also
Thor's mother Frigga who goes a bit
under use in these earlier films but
returns in a much larger role in endgame
notice our reaction when Odin greets
Thor tall
my first one yeah but the [ __ ] not
sure if a reaction is intentional but
yeah
Ragnarok reveals that Thor was not their
firstborn hella was perched on Odin's
throne are two Ravens these are named
Coogan thought and muninn memory and
they gather info from Midgard to relay
it to Odin Odin mentions kneel near was
forged in the heart of a dying star
which does give some explanation of its
impossible' density since dying stars
collapse an incredibly dense white
dwarves it also sets up these star
powered who Forge that Thor will have to
activate to create Stormbreaker but the
coordination gets interrupted I owned in
Nevada proclaim you hilarious accident
but also a fateful one foreshadowing how
the next person to take this throne of
Asgard will be the frost giant ascendant
located here Odum releases the destroyer
to fend them off now in the comics of
destroyers an enchanted suit of
Asgardian armor later comics Thor
actually Don's the farm at the destroyer
Loki manipulates Thor into vengeance on
Jotunheim and they head down the Bifrost
bridge to Heimdall now Kevin Feige said
that this bridge was actually one of the
trickier sets to design since
classically the Bifrost is just a
rainbow connecting Asgard to earth they
ended up decided on a solid quartz
bridge that catches the light flowing
through it in a way that splits into a
rainbow spectrum and that bridge ends in
Heimdall's Observatory Launchpad based
on the Hindman bjorg
which is Heimdall's mythological home
and notice how Heimdall greets loki here
you know dressed warmly enough more
evidence of Loki's frost giant past he
doesn't need to dress warmly because
he's going back to his homeland and then
Heimdall says never as an enemy slipped
my watch
- distant he plants is that low-key here
suspicious of this enemy that's looping
his watch
also this historic first breach of
Asgardian security could be seen as the
early stages of the Ragnarok event as it
is in lore the cycle of destruction
begins with Loki the gang heads do time
where they battle King lafi and the
frost elves Odin breaks it up on his
eight-legged horse Norse mythology owns
mounts flippin here is actually one of
the children of Loki Odin chastises them
back in Asgard with these actors firing
off some eloquent Shakespearean brogue
father ah as one of the best Shakespeare
directors sir Branagh basically conflict
on Henry v the story of a young king
it's actually very similar to Thor word
story Tom Hiddleston based Loki on Iago
from Othello and Edmund from King Lear
both are devious villains driven by Envy
and really some of the most active
characters of their stories despite
their names not being in the titles kind
of like Loki our secret hero in King
Lear Edmund is the illegitimate son of
the Earl of Gloucester jealous of his
legitimate brother Edgar and he tricks
his father into banishing Edgar into
exile paralleling Loki's position here
King Lear is really a story about
blindness in which Lear gains
metaphorical vision and insight only
after losing his literal eyesight which
is very much reflected in Odin's loss of
his eye and in the future Thor's loss of
his eye Odin exiles Thor and places this
charm on Mjolnir whoever holds this
hammer if he be worthy shall possess the
power soul this imprinted symbol shows
up often an association with Odin it's
called the triquetra which is a
religious symbol and its ancestor is the
German symbol the avout nut which is
associated with Odin and mythology of
course we now know this term is the
reason Steve Rogers was able to budge
Neil near an age of Ultron and fully
wielded an end game including summoning
lightning
Thor and Milner land in the desert of
New Mexico which is based on the comics
when following Ragnarok millionnaire and
Thor relocate to Oklahoma now it is hard
not to notice throughout the film the
prominent use of Dutch angles which is
when the camera tilts on a slant Branagh
defended it as a reflection of the
diagonal angles that he remembered in
comic book panels via matically it also
kind of reflects the way Thor's life was
thrown off balance since being cast out
of Asgard so right away we see this fun
expression of the god of thunders
depowered states he gets electrified by
Darcy's taser and the town's name is
point a and T whoa which in Spanish
means antique bridge
kind of like the ancient cosmic Bifrost
bridge that lands nearby and in their
lab they describe it as an
einstein-rosen bridge oh what a nice
time Rosen breach is a theoretical
connection between two different points
of space-time halt Bruce Banner will
actually use a similar explanation of
Ragnarok for the devil's eNOS that looks
like a collapsing neutron star inside of
an einstein-rosen bridge actually later
Selvig will mention banner as a
colleague though not by name I knew this
scientist pioneer in gamma radiation
there's actually a deleted take we're
cell big also references Hank Pym a
pioneer of shrinky dinks meanwhile mule
nears crater has become a site for
locals trying to pry it up like the
legend of King Arthur in the sword of
the Stone the first guy in the red truck
is a cameo by michael Straczynski writer
of thor comics another big time comics
writer Walt Simonson later cameos in the
closing beasts and of course we remember
the guy who rips the bed off his truck
cameo by Stan Lee later in the diner
scene you can see Stan's broken truck
driving by outside
Jane gives Thor a shirt of an
ex-boyfriend named Donald Blake the fake
alias that Thor will use in this movie
Donald Blake is the name of Thor's alter
ego in the comics which he used while
incognito since the ad libbed I am Iron
Man line the MCU has really avoided
secret identities for the most part
while Thor spends the second nights
eating and drinking
the real action is back on Asgard where
Loki learns his frost giant past Odin
confesses that it's opals that a king
with combined frost giant and Asgardian
roots could unite the two realms and
bring about peace which if you think
about it mixed Loki's ambition to the
throne a fairly worthy one Thor gets the
sustenance and Jane tells them no more
smashing Thor actually later shows some
maturity by echoing this to Hulk and
Ragnarok just for once in your life
don't slash outside the town are a few
Easter eggs a billboard reading home of
the Vikings and I tube these norse
warriors making this town their home
there's another billboard reading
journey into mystery the name of the
comic series where Thor first made his
debut Coulson joins the story
confiscating the research and equipment
joining him is Sitwell the recurring
SHIELD agent revealed as a Hydra
operative and Winter Soldier a deleted
scene actually shows these two
discussing why stark was sent to Ross
and the hulk post-credit scene to
deliberately piss off Ross so
abomination won't join The Avengers
initiative
Thor recharges and odinsleep leaving the
throne open to Loki though notice Odin's
Ravens have left this
thrown now relocated to Odin's bedside
because Ravens are boiled Selvig studies
up on Norse mythology kids edition
reading that Thursday is Thursday since
our days of the week have their names
rooted in that mythology there's also a
depiction of Odin and Thor crossing the
Bifrost with this cube which could be
the tesseract which we find out in hid
in tonsberg norway shield has taken over
the mule near crater
some say the overhead shot of the windy
ET tunnels appear to spell out the
letters s and then also H and I and E
and L and D but you know what you can
also spell out a B and an S Thor
infiltrates the site and shield calls in
agent Barton with Hawkeye jeremy renner
making his insulin u debut I mean even
with perfect day I'm a sniper rifle
might still have been a better weapon of
choice than a compound bow but as point
leader says no an unworthy jerk Thor
fails to lift me on the air and this
Square site is reflected lame doll's eye
showing how Thor's failure is known no
no Jane quotes arthur c clarke magics
just science that we don't understand
yet
arthur c clarke who wrote science
fiction a precursor to science fact
mark was a futurist and sci-fi writer
and co-wrote she doesn't want a Space
Odyssey and the quote here is a version
of his third law any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
for a magic this concept has been the
basis of the way the MCU has conflated
advanced science with magic which is why
magical concepts like time travel are
attempted to be granted in theoretical
physics and in game when ultimately that
movie had to just pull out the universes
top magic person to explain it in a way
that made sense so the big fries Thor
and we see another example of Thor's
broken confidence he drinks like a
lightweight compare is chugging here to
his drink in the doctor strange Loki
plots with lafi to kill Odin but notice
here that the snow now falls as wet
slate whereas before it looks like an
icy or blizzard reflecting Jotunheim 's
weaker in more desperate position
Thor assaults doing how science and
magic are the same thing they're not but
sure doodles oliver journal theo willed
is one of the nine
of the cosmos linked to each other by
the branches of Yggdrasil the world's
tree is all based on the eater seal
world's tree of Norse mythology and by
now in the MCU we actually have seen
most of the nine realms Asgard of course
Midgard is earth the current home of new
Asgard Jotunheim the home of the frost
giants Bertholf hime the home of Malek
Heath and the Dark Elves to see them in
the dark world vanaheim home to the
Vanier also seen in dark world
medieval ear home of the dwarves like a
tree and the rooms of which seen in
infinity war
nifflheim where hella came from in
Ragnarok Muspelheim home to the fire
demons like Surtur in Ragnarok and
Alfheim home to Alf actually the light
elves the one realm we have yet to see
lady SIF in the Warriors 3 head to earth
and Loki sends a destroyer that one of
Starks I don't know how this Ark
actually does acquire the destroyer
armor from Asgard and the beer itself
Comics as Thor battles the destroyer
Arturo's food and pharmacy can be seen
probably a nod to the King Arthur's
sword from the stone move that Thor
finally pulls here and after smashing
the destroyer actually going for the
head this time
Thor afterwards calls Coulson son of
coal going by his Asgardian naming
system since he's Odin son son of Odin
Loki feet raised lafi to win Odin and
fricos trust and he uses the Bifrost to
smash through Hylton time during our
discord watch along our good friend
Kirby squares shared the theory that
Loki's real goal might have been to
extend this bridge to Thanos on the
other side of unite I like this idea
because Santos would then get access to
Odin's vault and it suggests look he
might have been plotting in his alliance
with nanos even earlier than we thought
you can join future discord watch alongs
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash new rock stars
the two brothers fight Loki to see Thor
with some misdirection
the same kind of switcheroo that
Mysterio will try on spider-man in their
bridge battle and far from home door
smashes the bridge and while this seems
like a major sacrificial severance by
the hero the movie's secret hero severs
a link that can never be repaired
Loki lets go of Odin's scepter releasing
from the family succession that has been
chaining him down he sets himself free
now we learned later that Loki ends up
with a Chitauri
who thinks that Thanos give the secret
hero an even mightier sceptre in the
post-credits scene Nick Fury brings
Selvig in to project Pegasus to study
the tesseract Glee major MacGuffin of
the next two films and later revealed to
contain the space stone actually there's
a deleted scene that showed Salva quit
shield mentioning
sword database we cross-referenced them
with the sword
Dana me setting up the existence of
shields orbital offshoot sword and the
MC way earlier but Loki appears in the
reflection was Salva Kiir appearing to
control him later we learn of the power
of the tesseract drew of Loki's mind and
a madness and here he may be using this
link to project himself to Selvig I just
love that the final image is a smile
from the true victor of this film the
brother who learned his exact worth and
the reason we have an Avengers and a
Marvel Cinematic Universe does thinking
of Thor is Loki's movie change its
worthiness to you comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
Instagram or Twitter ID a box falling
rock stars and subscribe for more really
watches in the Infinity saga for next
one Captain America the First Avenger
gave me the line that embodies my
rewatched tenacity
[Music]